the seventh installment of the
mandalorian second season chapter 15 the
believer
was a grogu free-throw ride on a new
tropical planet
as always there were plenty of cool
easter eggs tucked away for fans to find
here are a few you may have missed
chapter 15
opens on the return of migs mayfeld the
mercenary and former imperial
sharpshooter
who double crossed mando in season 1.
when we catch up with him this time
around
he's now under new republic custody and
working at a scrapyard
note the old ad adds repurposed once
again as cranes
just like in chapter 11. mayfeld's luck
turns around on marshall karen dune
arrives to acquire his services
and knowledge to imperial protocols as
part of the plan to locate moff gideon
not looking to turn down the chance to
redeem himself he departs the planet
with her and mando's crew
passing by a familiar background alien
on his way out before he meets with dune
mayfeld walks past a wolf-like being
known as a hask
which is a fairly new breed to the star
wars franchise first appearing on screen
in 2015's the force awakens
we know from books and other media that
their culture is limited in regards to
their technology
but once they figured out space travel
many chose to take on odd jobs across
the galaxy
to help satiate their desire for chaos
and fans of star wars resistance
know that a good number of house could
join the ranks of quarren pirates trajin
gore
during the new republic era now aboard
boba fett ship slave 1
mayfeld has briefed on a situation
concerning grogu's abduction
and mando's plan to get him back the
only issue is for the ex-imperial to
gain access to moff gideon's coordinates
he needs to use an internal imperial
terminal
thus he points the crew in the direction
of the planet's morak to find one
however this won't be an easy task as a
good portion of the empire's remaining
forces
occupies and mines the planet for a
volatile fuel known as rhidonium
which has a long history in the star
wars universe first appearing in the
clone wars episode missing in action
rydonium is depicted as an incredibly
dangerous and highly explosive chemical
as a result it's frequently used as a
weapon of war just as often as it powers
military-grade transports since its
debut rhydonium has made its presence
felt all over star wars media
from rebels to the poe dameron centric
comic book series and as the mandalorian
proved when it does make the odd
appearance
it's best to look for cover as soon as
possible
while scoping out a way to infiltrate
the empire's base on morak
mando and his group determined that the
easiest way to sneak behind
enemy lines is for two of them to take
over an imperial fuel transport
and then disguise themselves as the
drivers initially cara dune is more than
prepared to join mayfeld for this phase
of their plan but he explains to her
that she can't do so
since the installation has the
technology to detect the genetic code of
those on new republic records
also he name drops a subdivision of the
imperial war machine
that appears to have dissolved with it
the imperial security bureau
or isb as mayfield refers to it was a
branch of the imperial intelligence
network that specialized in law
enforcement during the empire's heyday
fans of rebels should instantly
recognize the acronym as kallus made a
name for himself as an isp officer
before defecting to the rebel course and
those familiar with clone wars know that
former republic navy admiral wolf
yoloran who also appeared very briefly
in a new hope
became the commissioner of the isb
shortly after the empire
situated itself as a galaxy's new
governmental system
as mando and his team arrive on morack
they quickly realized that getting to
the imperial terminal
will be anything but easy the planet is
crawling with imperial loyalists
and plenty of pirates looking to
interrupt their operation by any means
necessary but still they go ahead with
their plan to infiltrate the local
installation
of course the empire didn't just send
run-of-the-mill stormtroopers
to guard the mine and fuel refineries
and instead diversified their ranks with
some other recognizable trooper classes
from different eras
of the star wars universe first and
foremost the design of the rhidonium
transport team's armor is reminiscent of
imperial hover tank pilots
from 2016's rogue one digging deeper
into the spin-off films plethora of
trooper designs
you'll notice that they also encounter a
large number of imperial shore troopers
nothing like the ones present during the
battle of scarif
additionally cara and fenix shan's
sniping puts a new hope-style death star
gunners in their crosshairs driving the
point home that the backbone of this
galaxy-wide regime isn't as disjointed
as many believe
having successfully infiltrated the
imperial base with only a mild amount of
trouble
from the locals mando and mayfield keep
their eyes peeled for the terminal and
find it rather swiftly however they run
into mayfeld's former commanding officer
valen hesse who commends them for their
successful delivery of the rydonium
not realizing their true intentions in
an apparent nod to the 1999 comedy
office space
mayfeld and mando attempt to elude hess
with an excuse about filling out
tps reports but it doesn't work uh you
apparently didn't put one of the new
cover sheets on your tps reports oh yeah
i'm sorry about that i i forgot mayfeld
also fibs and claims armando is hard of
hearing
following an incident on tanab tanab is
first mentioned on screen in return of
the jedi
when lando explains to han that a
maneuver he pulled off during a battle
on the planet got him promoted to
general
valenhest invites mando and mayfeld to
join him for a drink and some
reminiscing over the empire's finest
moments including the short-lived
operation cinder made famous by the 2017
star wars battlefront 2 video game
after the death of emperor palpatine and
the destruction of the second dexter
imperial sentinels directed the
remaining forces to begin carrying out a
plan
known as a contingency one aspect of it
dubbed operation cinder was devised by
the sith lord personally
it effectively destroyed planets across
the galaxy that were once under
imperial control large climate
disrupting satellites placed above
specific
imperial worlds annihilated their
ecology and residence
ensuring that the empire and its enemies
didn't continue in the event of
palpatine's death
it's a pretty twisted concept but it's
fairly on brand for a regime
bred from the dark side check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the mandalorian
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one